ANGELA PRIMAVERA:
Hi, everyone.
I'm Angela Primavera, curriculum
specialist here at
the Google Children's Center.
And when I was thinking about
a phrase that could describe
our next guest, what kept coming
to mind was the power
of connection.
For anyone who's been to a
Michael Franti show, you know
that he has a way of reaching
out to each and every member
of the audience.
For over 20 years, Michael has
found a way to connect not
only with his musical fans, but
people around the globe.
Whether it's bridging a
conversation using just his
guitar, as documented in his
film "I Know I'm Not Alone,"
or utilizing technology to
connect to his fans in FranTV,
or even his Power to the
Peaceful festivals right here
in the Bay Area, Michael Franti
embraces the power of
connection.
More recently, he's used his
poetic abilities to connect
with our newest generation of
environmental stewards in his
children's book "Where in the
World Is Away?" In partnership
with Talks at Google, Google
Play, and the Google
Children's Center's Parent
Education Series, I'm honored
to offer Googlers this
opportunity to connect once
again with Michael Franti.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL FRANTI: How's
it going, y'all?
How you feeling?
All right.
Well, I was really excited to
come to Google today because,
well, there's this urban myth
about Google, which is--
that I--
can you push that
in for me, Jay?
That I believed up until about
15 minutes ago, which is that
when you type in something on
Google, there's this giant
room full of 1,000 people
in lab coats.
And they see what you've typed
in, like Roberto Clemente's
batting average in 1967.
And then a guy gets up, and he
runs down this corridor to
this shelf full of books
and encyclopedias.
And he pulls it out, and
he thumbs through it.
And then he slams it shut,
and then he runs back.
And he types in 323.
And I found out that it's
not actually true.
So maybe you should
be a myth buster.
JAY BOWMAN: Myth buster.
MICHAEL FRANTI: But it is true
that kids love music, right?
Make noise, kids.
I love this kid with
the sunglasses.
So let play some music.
It goes like this.
One, two, three.
Uh-huh.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Kids, put
your hands together.
There you go.
Moms and dads, how
you feeling?
All the Googlers,
how you feeling?
Here we go.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Let me
hear you sing this.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: One, two,
put your hands together.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Jay Boogie,
play that guitar.
Come on, now.
Kids, I want to see
your air guitar.
Get it going now.
There you go.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Make
some noise.
Break it down now.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: OK, kids.
I got something for you to do.
OK, ready?
What do you--
what does it look like?
Can you do a dance for when
I say the word sound?
How about, that's the sound.
Put your hand up by your ear.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: All right.
You guys got it now.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: I want to
hear you sing it now.
Ready?
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: One
more time now.
Real loud, everybody.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Now kids, I
want to hear you scream.
[SCREAMS]
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"THE SOUND OF SUNSHINE"]
And that's
MICHAEL FRANTI: Make
some noise!
Aiya!
All right.
You having fun?
Yay.
Awesome.
Well, I wrote a book.
I wrote two books, actually.
This one's called "What I Be,"
and this one's called "Where
in the World is Away?"
I'm going to read from this one
today because April is a
very important month.
Do you know why April is
an important month?
We have a birthday that we
celebrate in April every year.
And you know who was
born in April?
The earth.
The earth was-- you
can Google it.
Earth was born in April.
And this is a book that's about
taking care of our Earth.
And it's called, "Where in the
World is Away?" And it goes a
little something like this.
Little Lee and little
Lou sat by a lake,
sharing a bottle of juice.
It was a warm, sunny day, and
the birds where at play.
And they smiled as they
watched mama goose.
As they finished the drink, Lou
pulled back his arm and
said, I'm going to
throw it away.
Stop, Lou.
Think, before you make
a mistake, where in
the world is away?
If we throw it in the lake,
it's gone for today.
But is that really away?
Not for the frogs who hip hop
on the logs or the fish who
jump up in the air or the little
tiny things that live
off the greens that grow on
the bottom down there.
All of our spills just fill up
their gills, and it's so hard
to breathe without air.
They play hide and
go seek, and they
think, school is cool.
So we shouldn't make
a mess down there.
I've got a plan, Lou
started to say.
Over the hill's where
I'll throw it away.
Not so fast, Lou,
if I may say.
Is over the hill there
really away?
What do you kids think?
Is that really away?
AUDIENCE: No.
MICHAEL FRANTI: No.
That's where the forest
grows, tall and wide.
And all kinds of critters
live deep inside.
It's cool in the daytime
and warm at night.
And squirrels do twirls while
birds are in flight.
There's nuts, and
there's berries.
There's bears, and there's
fairies and a
butterfly up in a tree.
By the light of the moon, they
play drums with raccoons as
the mice shout, one,
two, three.
Can I hear you kids say, one,
two, three, like mice?
AUDIENCE: One, two, three.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Yay!
[LAUGHS]
But if the forest has bottles
on a hot, sunny day, the sun
magnifies and might set it
ablaze, then all of the forest
beings would run
with a fright.
We don't want that, Lou.
No, you're right.
Lou said, let's just throw
it here on the street.
Someone will come and
eventually sweep.
But look down below, even
up through the cracks.
There grows the tiniest
blades of green grass.
And where there is grass,
then grasshoppers be.
And where there are
grasshoppers,
let's let them be.
And besides, we all like to
keep the street neat.
And we don't need glass where
there might be bare feet.
There's far too much garbage.
It's just got to stop.
The landfills are filling
right up to the top.
Then where is away, said
confused little Lou.
And what of the bottle when
there's no more juice?
They spotted a bin with a round
symbol on it, and can
with the word recycling on it.
And inside the can there were
hundreds of bottles in all
kinds of shapes and
colors and models.
If we put it in there, will it
go away, sweet little Lou
started to say.
Lee opened her mouth to
say, we'll never know.
And just as she did,
along came a crow.
This grow at her feet was oh,
so unique, a crow named Mo
with a beak that could speak.
Good heavens, they shouted.
How could this be?
The crow said, relax.
It's just a little old me.
If you'd like to know where old
bottle should go, close
your eyes, spread your wings,
and follow this crow.
The bottles are picked up by
truck and transported to a
glass sorting center, then
they are sorted.
Green ones go there, and
brown ones go here.
There's places for blue and
for yellow and clear.
All of the paper and
caps are removed.
And yes, even those things
are recycled too.
All of the glass gets crushed
into cullet, a word you
mightn't heard, but that's
what they call it.
Then it's thrown into a
furnace to heat to a
temperature of over
2000 degrees.
And then when it's melted,
it glows into goo.
And then there are so many
things you can do.
You can bend it and shape it and
pour it into molds, make
magical art work or
things to be sold.
And when it cools down, it
turns hard very fast and
quickly returns int shiny,
smooth glass.
It makes mirrors and lamps and
grape jelly jars, even
eyeglasses and windows
for cars.
There's so many things,
so many to choose.
And yes, you can even make
bottles for juice.
So always recycle, said
crow with a smile.
And reduce what you use
every once in a while.
When you reach for that bottle
high up on the shelf, remember
away is just somewhere else.
There's so many choices,
said sweet little Lou.
But this here bottle, we're
going to reuse.
And they each put
a flower in it.
The end.
Yay!
All right.
Let's play some more music.
You guys ready for a song?
This one, you have to
repeat after me.
OK?
It goes--
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI &
SPEARHEAD, "HELLO BONJOUR"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Put your
hands together now.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI &
SPEARHEAD, "HELLO BONJOUR"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Jay,
play that guitar.
Come on now.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI &
SPEARHEAD, "HELLO BONJOUR"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Ow!
Kids, I want to see you get
up and play your guitars.
There you go.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI &
SPEARHEAD, "HELLO BONJOUR"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Yeah!
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL FRANTI: You sound
so good, kids.
Big kids, too.
I like that dance you were
doing over there.
Yeah.
All right.
So how many kids here recycle
at your house?
If you're with your parents,
don't embarrass them.
You recycle?
What do you do?
Tell me how you do it?
AUDIENCE: Put the garbage
in the recycling bin.
MICHAEL FRANTI: You put your
things, your garbage in the
recycling bin?
Do you separate it out,
like bottles and cans?
Or do you just put
it in one thing?
Yeah.
Awesome.
What do you do?
The same thing?
What about you?
AUDIENCE: I use the stuff I
don't want to turn into
something else.
MICHAEL FRANTI: You use the
stuff that you don't want, and
then they turn it into
something else?
That's awesome, man.
That's so cool.
Anybody else?
You in the back there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Can
you help out, dad?
I couldn't hear.
AUDIENCE: Break the glass into
little pieces and make it into
something else.
MICHAEL FRANTI: You break the
glass into little pieces and
make it into something else.
I love that.
That was fun.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL FRANTI: All right.
Nice.
Any other kids?
Do you compost?
JAY BOWMAN: Wow.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Can you
tell us about that?
How about if mom tells us, and
you just nod your head?
AUDIENCE: We put all of our
food scraps in a bowl, and
then it gets turned into dirt.
Is that what we do?
MICHAEL FRANTI: Nice.
Do kids know what that
is, composting?
It's when you take all
your food scraps, and
you put it in a bowl.
And then you put it in a
place in your garden,
and worms eat it.
And then the worms poop it out,
and it turns into dirt.
That's pretty cool.
What were you going to say?
AUDIENCE: Nothing.
MICHAEL FRANTI: OK.
You?
AUDIENCE: My sister's
magic and turns
stuff into other stuff.
AUDIENCE: Her sister's
magic turns other
stuff into other stuff.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Your sister's
magic turns the cycling into
other things?
That's awesome.
Awesome.
Cool.
All right.
Well, we were going to just open
it up to any questions
for any Googlers, perhaps
if you have for
us, about any subject.
It doesn't have to be about
worms and poop.
But it can also be about
that, if you want.
ANGELA PRIMAVERA: I'll go
ahead and start it off.
MICHAEL FRANTI: OK, go ahead.
ANGELA PRIMAVERA: And for those
of you on the VC, you
can add it to the Dory
at goto slash Franti.
Or anybody here can go ahead
and step up to the mic.
So you found an inspirational
way to use your voice to
connect with those around you.
Is there a message that you
have for some of our young
children here about the
power of their voice?
MICHAEL FRANTI: Well, my message
to every kid here is
that all of us are different.
And being different
is beautiful.
When you look in your house at
something that's like a salad,
if you have tomatoes in there
and carrots and greens and
sprouts and--
what are kinds of things you
guys put in your salads?
What do you put in your
salad at home?
Avocado?
I love avocado.
Tea?
JAY BOWMAN: Cheese.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Cheese.
Oh, yeah.
We love cheese.
What?
Fruits.
Yeah.
Yeah, fruits.
So the more things that are in
the salad, the more beautiful
and tasty the salad is.
And that's the same thing with
people in our world.
The more difference that we have
and the more diversity--
we call it-- that we respect
and love and honor and
cherish, the better
the world is.
So that's my message to kids,
same as to adults.
Be your authentic self.
Live your truth.
AUDIENCE: Pizza.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Pizza.
You put pizza in your salad?
You do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: What'd you say?
I didn't hear.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Nice, nice.
You put salad in the garbage
when it's done.
ANGELA PRIMAVERA: I'll go ahead
and ask another one.
MICHAEL FRANTI: OK, cool.
ANGELA PRIMAVERA: Feel free to
hop up on the mic there.
We also have books for those of
you that would like to ask
a question of Michael.
What is something you've learned
from fatherhood that
you'd like to share with us?
MICHAEL FRANTI: That I'm
wrong most of the time.
Being a dad, you have to make
it up as you go along.
I have one son who's 25 and
another son who's 14.
And I was really young when
I had my first son.
And so when you have a kid, your
first kid, your time--
you have to do all the wonderful
things in life that
you do, like go to parties and
hang out at the beach and do
all these things.
It gets eliminated.
And so you have the time
with your kids.
And then you have like just
that one hour or two hours
that you have for yourself
every day.
And so what I did during that
time is I would take care of
my son all day and then
put him to sleep.
And he would go off with his mom
after that in the night.
And I'd go to work at night at
nightclubs in San Francisco.
But I'd have one or
two hours at home.
And I would just write.
I had these yellow legal pads
of paper that I would
write lyrics on.
And at first, I was like,
man, my time is gone.
But then it really makes
you think about
what you want to do.
What's the most important
thing that you want to
do with your time?
And for me, it was writing.
And so it really helped me to
hone in on what I love and
what my passion is and to really
do my best during those
moments that I had.
And my mom was--
she is an amazing woman.
Mrs. Franti adopted me.
And she had three kids
of her own with my
father, Charles Franti.
And they're Finnish Americans.
And they adopted myself and
another African American son.
So we grew up in this house,
a diverse household.
I have one sister
who's lesbian.
And it's a very mixed
household.
And one time I asked my mom.
I said, what did you
do with us kids?
You worked as a school
teacher for 35 years.
Then you'd come home and
deal with us five kids.
And she said, every
day I'd come home.
And I had one expectation of all
of you, which is that when
you went out into our
neighborhood, you treated
everybody as good or better
than you wanted to
be treated at home.
And she said, I tried to teach
all of you kids and treat all
of you kids exactly the same,
which meant that if one of us
got a lollipop, then all
of us had to share it.
I'm just kidding.
I don't advise that
to any parent.
But she insisted that we
treat every kid in our
neighborhood the same.
And she said that the greatest
gift that any parent could
give their children is wings.
And the wings are the self
confidence you have, that when
you're in whatever precipice
in your life, that you feel
like I have the ability to
jump off and fly and face
whatever it is that this
challenge is in my life.
And so that's what I try to
do with both my sons.
And my mom did a really
great job with that,
I think, with me.
ANGELA PRIMAVERA: All right.
We have a question from
the audience.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thank you for coming out.
And we really appreciate it.
MICHAEL FRANTI: You're
welcome.
AUDIENCE: What's the story
behind you being barefoot?
And how often do you run into
a place where you think, no,
probably not going
to go there?
MICHAEL FRANTI: Well, man,
walking onto the Google
campus, I was like, ew, with a
name like Google, I don't know
if I even want to--
no.
I've been barefoot--
it'll be 13 years on my
birthday, which is at the end
of this month.
And I started walking barefoot
in countries where kids
couldn't afford to wear shoes.
And I'd go out and I'd play
soccer with them and stuff.
And so I would take off my shoes
just to not stomp on
their feet or whatever.
And I could barely
take three steps.
I was like, ouch, ouch, ouch.
So I decided to go home.
And for three days, I was
going to go barefoot.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
When did you learn guitar?
AUDIENCE: When did
you learn guitar?
MICHAEL FRANTI: When
did I learn guitar?
I learned guitar not
too long ago.
I've only been playing
guitar about seven or
eight years, actually.
Yeah.
I started really late.
I'll tell you more about
that in a minute.
But so I decided to go barefoot
for three days.
And three days turned into
a week and into a
month and into a year.
And my son's waving
at me back there.
He's like, dad, your
feet are gross.
And there are times when I feel
like, wow, it's really
gross around here.
But I'm just more observant
of where I step.
It's funny that you have to wear
shoes when you go into
the airport, and then you have
to take them off when you go
through the security.
And then you got to put
them back on again.
Then when you get on
the plane, you can
take them off again.
So I always carry a pair of
flip-flops around that are for
those kind of moments.
And I never do it out of
any form of protest.
If I'm somewhere, and they say,
please put your shoes on,
I always put my flip-flops on.
And that's kind of the story.
And when it was the tenth
anniversary of me being
barefoot, I partnered with
this organization called
Soles4Souls.
And we collect used shoes
for kids and families
all around the world.
It started after Hurricane
Katrina.
A lot of people left their
homes without shoes.
And so they started collecting
shoes for that.
But now we're in Haiti, South
America, Africa, places in
Asia, all over the world.
Oh, so my guitar--
I went on this trip to this
place called Cuba.
And I was there with a group of
musicians from around the
world who are collaborating
with Cuban artists.
And we were there singing the
songs that we'd written
together during a week.
And so every night, this guitar
would get passed around
this table.
And everybody would sort of sing
these wonderful boleros
off into the Cuban Havana
moonlit night with bottles of
rum and cigars being
passed around.
And probably should lay off the
cigars and rum till you
get your first chords
down, at least.
And so I decided, I'm never
going to be caught in this
situation when I can't
play guitar.
And so a year passed.
And I was at this great
festival up in Oregon.
And the same thing, the guitar
got passed to me.
And all I could do was go--
[MUSIC - THE SUGARHILL GANG,
"RAPPER'S DELIGHT"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: So I decided,
golly, I'm going
to learn the guitar.
So finally, another
year passed.
And I was in another
embarrassing situation.
And I was up with a friend of
mine who's a farmer up in
Humboldt County.
And I decided this would be the
perfect place to sit on
his porch for hours and learn
my first guitar chords.
And I've been playing now about
seven, eight years.
And I love it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks again for coming here.
It is just terrific to have
people like you come visit us.
So you've had this
amazing career.
Musically, you've done an
incredible range of things,
and then outside of music, from
video stuff to writing
children's books to just
social projects.
What are you most proud of?
And what do you think is going
to have the biggest legacy?
MICHAEL FRANTI: Well,
it's the same thing,
the two same things.
I'm most proud of my kids.
And hopefully, my kids have
the biggest legacy.
Right?
High five, son.
There's a lot of things that
I've done in music.
And the most memorable things
are being in places where
music is absent most of the
time and then going and
bringing music there and seeing
the environment change
immediately.
AUDIENCE: You had such an
eclectic career from your
activism, social justice,
your films, to music.
What inspired you to jump
into children's
books of all things?
And then I think what you
previously just said might
explain that already.
But--
MICHAEL FRANTI: Yeah.
OK.
Well, my favorite artists
have been--
my favorite artists are Bob
Marley, Marvin Gaye, John
Lennon, and Johnny Cash.
And the reason is because they
both-- or all of them were
able to write songs about how
much they wanted to see the
world be a better place.
And then they would also write
a song right next to it about
how much they love
their girlfriend.
And I've always felt like if
you can't do both, or if
you're only settled on just
doing one of those things,
then you're missing so much
of what it's about.
And so that's why I do
the different things.
That's why I go to Iraq and play
music on the street and
make a film about that and then
write a children's book,
like this book, the other book
that's here, "What I Be,"
which is about being yourself.
And really, the message
is the same thing.
It's about reaching out to other
people and being the
person that you are and then
being able to embrace other
people for being the person
that they are.
And my mom used to always tell
me, it's not enough--
she hated the word tolerance.
That was a buzz word.
We need to have tolerance.
And there's a Museum of
Tolerance, which is a
fantastic place.
But she never liked the
word tolerance,
because it was always--
you tolerate getting your teeth
grinded at the dentist.
But she liked the words like
embrace and to honor and to
respect and cherish because
she's always felt like we
should be that towards other
people, towards other
cultures, other walks of life,
that to really live life and
to live a fullness for yourself
is to find the beauty
in other things that are
different than you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Yeah.
ANGELA PRIMAVERA: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Did you do
any Johnny Cash
songs at San Quentin?
"Folsom Prison," or
"Cocaine Blues?"
MICHAEL FRANTI: It was funny.
Before we-- we also played
in Folsom Prison.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wow.
MICHAEL FRANTI: And we were
the first artists playing
there in 37 years since Johnny
Cash had done it.
And when we went in, the warden
of the prison required
that I send a list of the songs
that I was going to sing
and all the lyrics.
And he went through line item,
veto style, and said, you
can't sing this line.
You can't sing this line.
And you can't sing this song.
And at first, I was like,
man, this is not cool.
I'm not going to do this.
I got a pride feather
sticking out of me.
And then I thought, these
cats are locked
down for a long time.
And who am I to not sing or not
show up because the warden
won't let me sing a song?
This is not the protest
that I want to make.
So the answer to your question,
no, we weren't
allowed to.
And no, I didn't
AUDIENCE: Oh, wow.
Just Sesame Street.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Well, there's
plenty of other
songs besides that.
But that's what--
one of the things that we come
across as musicians is where
are our values?
And what are the lines that
we choose to cross?
Are we going to put a
song in this movie?
And if we put a song in the
movie, are we going to put a
song in the commercial that
goes along with the movie?
And then if that commercial also
has a partnership with
some brand, do we support
that brand?
Do we allow the song
to be in there?
And at the end of the day, I
always feel like I'm out there
every day of my life on tour,
singing things and expressing
the things I can in the best
way I can for whatever the
situation is.
But I'll talk to these kids
differently than I would kids
in San Quentin.
AUDIENCE: What I really want to
ask though was about, when
you were a kid, what was
your favorable books?
Or do your kids have
any favorite?
MICHAEL FRANTI: Oh, yeah.
My favorite books were the
"Curious George" books.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Yeah.
And "Harold and the Purple
Crayon." And then all of the
Roald Dahl books, and especially
"Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Facotory."
AUDIENCE: What about music
when you were young?
What was the first
stuff that you
listened to and then after?
MICHAEL FRANTI: The first stuff
that I listened to was
music that was in my house that
my brothers and sisters
were playing.
So it was Al Green, Jim
Croce, Carole King.
And then it was The Clash and
Parliament-Funkadelic and The Police.
And then it became Run-DMC.
Somewhere in all of that was
the "Saturday Night Fever"
soundtrack which didn't leave
the turntable for a long time.
Earth, Wind & Fire.
And then once I went through
all that stuff, I went
straight into hardcore punk rock
for many years and just
listen exclusively to all the
great Bay Area bands, Dead
Kennedys and the Circle Jerks
and all the bands that were
touring through here.
ANGELA PRIMAVERA: All right.
We'll take one more
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I want to say, thanks
for coming.
Your message that
you're sending--
it's really positive.
And you're doing a great
job inspiring
children as well as adults.
MICHAEL FRANTI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm also an aspiring
writer myself.
My question goes out to--
it's for adults but
also for children.
Can you give us words and
advice in overcoming a
challenging situation or whether
it's music, writing,
or just in life in general?
MICHAEL FRANTI: Well, I think
that if you get yourself out
of your comfort zone a lot of
the time, then it becomes more
familiar crossing over those
lines where you don't feel
comfortable or where
you feel scared.
I practice yoga.
And in our practice of yoga,
we put ourselves into
uncomfortable positions.
And we learn how to breathe
while we're going through
these really intense
stretches.
And to quiet our mind and say,
I'm not going to listen to
this voice that's saying I'm
not good enough or I'm not
limber enough or I'm too
tired or whatever--
and we practice the exercise
so that when we get into
uncomfortable situations in
our day to day life, they
become easier.
And they're still not.
It's still always hard.
But writing a book is something
that I never
imagined I would do.
But I made a five year
plan at one point.
And I said, there's a few things
that I want to do.
I want to write a book.
I want to make a film.
I want to start a yoga school.
And I wanted to get my band
to a certain level of
musicianship and get ourselves
out touring at a certain level
and had goals in that regard.
And just to write them down,
those goals, was really
helpful for me.
And then I said, I'm not going
to prioritize them in terms of
what's most important, because
they're all really
important to me.
But I prioritized
them in terms of
what was most imminent.
So in order to become a better
musician, I needed to take
guitar lessons.
So that became in the A pile.
And then there was the
B pile of things and
the C pile of things.
So writing stuff down and then
creating a priority of--
I need to-- if I'm going
to write a book, I
got to do this first.
And then I got to find the
illustrator second.
Then I got to figure out
a way to publish it.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
Thank you.
MICHAEL FRANTI: You're
welcome.
ANGELA PRIMAVERA: All right.
You got another song for us?
MICHAEL FRANTI: I do.
Yup.
ANGELA PRIMAVERA: All right.
Thank you.
MICHAEL FRANTI: All right.
Let's do [INAUDIBLE].
JAY BOWMAN: OK.
MICHAEL FRANTI: So we need
some kids up here.
We need some kids up
here to dance.
Come on up.
All right.
Are you guys ready?
OK.
Any other kids who want to come
up here, just feel free
to join us.
Any adults that want to come up,
feel free to join us too.
OK.
It goes like this.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: OK, kids.
You ready?
Ready to dance?
One, two, three, come on now.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Put your
hands up high.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Woo.
You want to sing it?
It goes like this.
I'll teach you how it goes.
Come over here to
the microphone.
Ready?
It goes--
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: A
little louder.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Adults, we need
an adult to come up here.
You, young man, get up here.
JAY BOWMAN: That's right.
Come on up here, big boy.
MICHAEL FRANTI: It goes--
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
AUDIENCE: Was that right?
Was that right?
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Yeah!
One, two, three, come on.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Put your
hands together.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Let
me hear you.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Everybody now.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Sounds good.
On your feet.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Everybody
on your feet now.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: This
is the last time.
I want to see everybody
in here jumping.
[MUSIC - MICHAEL FRANTI
& SPEARHEAD,
"SAY HEY (I LOVE YOU)"]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Google, give it
up for these kids up here.
Give it up for Jay Boogie
on the guitar.
Give it up for all the people
here at Google who take care
of all the kids at Google.
We love you.
I'm Michael.
Thanks for having
me here today.
Give it up for Jay Boogie
one more time.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL FRANTI: Thanks, y'all.